[Music]
i can lead i can make tough decisions
and i can get things done i am ready to
be prime minister from day one
[Music]
because i believe like most liberal
democrats in democracy
democracy with a capital g
[Music]
we are facing an unprecedented problem
with like war in ukraine energy prices
rising
amazing intra
ai climate change the shift to power to
the east is she actually convincing
people that she is the person to deal
with all of those massive issues and i
think that the jury's very much out on
that at the moment
[Music]
well she's been talking about a lot
about tax cuts
less about targeted relief for people on
low incomes because of high energy
prices
in terms of our overall positioning you
know she's been a member of the current
government but what do we know about
what she'd be like as prime minister
with a series of policy problems facing
her actually we know surprisingly little
[Music]